Okay.
So we look at the traditional view of the community,
have the three pillars,
the economy,
environment and society.
And traditionally we have dealt with these issues as being separate.
Uh,
when you look historically over the past century,
we have separated these things out as if they are sadly not related.
It's only recently,
it's only since the type of Brundtland,
um,
systems thinking over the past 20,
30 years that people have,
uh,
recognize that the traditional solution can actually cause problems.
And that if you wind up focusing only on economic growth and job creation,
you can do that in a way that is going to be extremely harmful to,
uh,
for instance your environment or if you,
if you focus only and the other side,
the way that if you only focus on environment,
you might be impairing
cultural or,
or societal,
uh,
traditions.
So
an important point is these piecemeal,
fragmented solutions also,
um,
are directly related to a lot of the,
uh,
the,
the agendas and mobilizing opposing groups.
Um,
so rather than looking at things as a system where you are looking to optimize
solutions,
you instead I'm mobilizing,
mobilizing agendas and mobilizing opposition.
And too often we tend to focus on short term benefits.
Um,
and that we could go into a long discussion about why that is,
whether it's our current economic valuation models,
whether it's because we have certain election and political cycles or uh,
attention spans is a lot of reasons why we could talk about that.
All right?
Now,
does anybody want to argue that these things aren't interlinked because
certainly we have just a decades if not centuries of data showing that,
um,
you can't play the old kind of a game whack-a-mole with the,
uh,
with these problems where the Taco one and then another one pops up.
Um,
now this is the slide that I think is about as obvious as something can be in,
it astounds me that this is not how many people consciously think about things.
So we know that our economy exists within society to serve society and Society
of course exists within the greater environment.
You would think by listening to some of our discussions that this was up for
debate,
that when the economy
is,
uh,
somehow viewed as being equal or more often superior to the society that it's
supposed to serve.
There's a great saying that I,
I believe is from Paul Hawkin that markets are a miraculous tool,
a terrible master,
and an even worse religion.
So you start thinking about when we talk about market forces,
the whole reason that these market forces exist is to serve the greater society
and society cannot exist without the natural capital,
the natural resources,
the,
they are life giving atmosphere that the environment writ large provides.
So when we start talking about these relationships,
which we are going to need to talk about in depth,
we're going to be talking about,
you know,
this chemical producers,
this adhesive produces,
this drug's gonna.
It doesn't make economic sense of,
I want everybody to always keep this in mind because again,
it astounds me how long,
how often this relationship seems to be lost in the general discussion.